i just thought i'd drop a quick live
video
just to say what is happening tonight um
there's been a few
issues with the financial freedom
challenge so i just wanted to talk a
little bit about what's happening
so i'll just give a second for a couple
people to jump on and
then i'll give you the lowdown oh it's
been rough
okay so i don't know if you guys can
if there's people on i think there are
hey what's happening
so we're live and so basically this this
is just
a video an apology video uh
also a little bit of a disclaimer about
what's going on hey what's happening
juliet hall
martin black tears jacob ben
what is happening so
i i was gonna be publishing the
financial freedom challenge
tonight at 7 p.m and the challenge was
as i've said before it was a very
very very tough challenge i deserve to
be on your program for frasier's random
channel
awesome call okay um
so chris thank you so listen the
financial freedom challenge it is i am
publishing it tonight it's coming out
there's just been a little bit of a
delay and the delay was i watched the
whole thing
for the very first time tonight
about two hours ago as like just a final
approval thing and i was like okay cool
yeah let me watch it i'm sure it's fine
i'd already decided it was fine
there were some things that happened in
the documentary
that were so raw
and i was just like ouch like
ow um and i was okay with it but i just
felt like i
had to run it past lawton lawson's gonna
is in the documentary it's about lauren
so his
his credibility is on the line as well
as well as mine
so basically i had to run it past him i
had to play him a couple of bits
then i had to start the upload so it is
do you have anxiety sometimes says
paradise fitness
um not really no i wouldn't say i have
anxiety
probably i'm probably tonight i feel a
little bit anxious because of this
this uh this video but anyway so it's
coming
it's right now it is uploading to
youtube it's at one hour and seven
minutes long
so it's an hour and seven minutes long
and because of that um
it's gonna take a little while to upload
so it is uploading it is coming
and it's gonna be right now it says
that there is it's about two hours and
24
minutes so it's gonna be around about 10
p.m by the time it comes out
and um yeah someone says is it that bad
yeah it is it is that bad i mean
there's parts that are really good
did we did we genuinely failed the
financial freedom challenge yes we did
we we genuinely
we genuinely failed the financial
freedom challenge um
did we did we have some success and make
some money and do some good things yeah
we did
um did we get any passive income no did
we get any rent to rent no i think it
was more just the awkwardness of the
embarrassment of
what happened with some of the agents
and things you know
it was really rough okay that's all i'm
gonna say it was really really really
rough
lawton was you know
very emotional on camera
it wasn't when i did the financial
freedom challenge with evans
last month it was just like bang bang
bang bang
smashed out the park call i expected it
to be the same with lauren
so when i did it with lawton and when it
didn't go like that
i was like damn you know at all that's
why i was just like
okay this kind of like threw me a little
bit and i felt like i had to show lauren
so anyway it's coming out i'm so sorry
it's not coming out at 7 00 p.m
like i always do a video at 7 pm so i
guess the question is
um not the question but i would love it
if you guys could just
you know support support what happened
we didn't have to film it we could have
just done it
i could have just moved into his house
lived even for a week and said look dude
i'm gonna come and live with you and i'm
gonna try and help you become
financially free
for seven days and we didn't have to
film it we did film it
we didn't have to put it out but
you know we just figured it'll be it'll
be the right thing to do
so it is coming it's coming out in the
next couple of hours or so
um and you know what i would really say
you're probably gonna learn more from
this challenge than from any of the
previous ones
there were some big wins there were some
big losses there was a lot of reward but
there was also risk there was a lot of
up but there was
a lot of dams more so than normal uh
overall yes we failed
where are you that's not your house
um yeah no i'm just i'm just in a hotel
right now yeah i'm out
i'm out just doing some property deals
so i'm in a hotel
um is manchester a good city to invest
in yeah i think manchester is a good
city
to invest in is it an easy city to get
rent to rents
uh no i'll tell you one thing though
about what happened with with lauren
we tried our absolute hardest you know
so
anyway please support it hopefully
you'll stick around
this evening you'll step late to watch
it uh let me know in the comments if
you're gonna be if you're gonna be
watching it tonight let me know in the
comments
that'll be awesome what time is the
video out so the video is currently
uploading
to youtube so it should be out in about
two hours and 20 minutes
so around about 10 p.m ish might be a
little bit later depending on how
how fast the wi-fi is here um we are
here
graziella thank you so much you're
incredible i really appreciate you
graziella
um and thank you also graziella for
actually helping
um with the challenge like
you know you really really helped so
thank you for that
um that's great great to see people are
going to be watching it
um awesome awesome
so yeah folks that's it it's coming out
it's interesting that it's almost like
the one i did with evans was just so
easy
i think i think i went in a little bit
too comfortable maybe that's my lesson
maybe i got a little bit too comfortable
and that's why
it was just so hard but as i say it's
not all
doom um if people can learn from it then
it's a big win
we got some super big wins in the
challenge
but we just didn't manage to make any um
you know certainly any passive income we
did make some money
you got cocky yeah maybe maybe i've got
maybe i think as well like with the
financial freedom challenges
i never prepare for them in terms of
prepare like like jeez i did one of them
in in america i went to the airport not
knowing where i was going to be so you
can't prepare for an ff challenge in
terms of
you don't know what's going to happen
but i think maybe i didn't prepare
you know maybe i didn't prepare mentally
maybe i was just like ah it's gonna be
fine and just kind of maybe went in with
the wrong mentality
um you let me know in the comments
once you've seen it let me know your
thoughts and um
it's all perspective you know it's all
perspective in terms of i was saying
this to law and i was like
would you consider the the financial
freedom challenge a failure or a success
and we were chatting about that we were
saying it's all perspective you could
you could look at it and you could say
it was a complete fail
because we he's not financially free or
even
close or you could look at it and you
could
actually it was a raging success because
we did some really good deals we learned
some really big lessons
um you know so it's all perspective so
i'm interested in what you think
it's coming out soon thank you for your
support you know and um
yeah stay tuned see you real soon i'll
be watching it live by the way
okay so if you're gonna stay up tonight
and watch it
i'll be there in the comments we're
going to live
premiere it so if you're up
watch it and i'll be able to share my
thoughts along the way you can ask
questions and stuff like that
andrew it thank you so much if you've
learned something then that's a success
100
100 um what time
in about two hours or so uh
round about 10 o'clock depending on how
how long it takes my wi-fi
so i'll see you real soon thank you so
much and
i'll see you at about 10 o'clock thanks